today we're going to talk about the sign
convention for passive components it's a
big mouthful but it's a fairly simple
idea first of all let's look at this
word passive passive is the way we
describe components that do not create
power or components that do not amplify
signals so particularly resistors as we
have one here does not amplify a signal
capacitors and inductors do not either
so they're both all three of those are
passive components and sometimes we say
something like a battery or a voltage
source is a passive component because it
can't amplify a signal it does provide
power but it does not make signals
bigger it can't make a voltage larger
than it already is so we're going to
start with the way to label this
resistor with its current and voltage
first we'll go resort to Ohm's law our
friend voltage equals current which is I
times R and when we label this when we
label this device here's here's resistor
so we'll give that a label and we're
going to put a voltage across this
something outside of this is going to
put a voltage across it and this end
will be positive with respect to this
end and the question is the question we
want answer is which direction does the
current go when there's positive
voltages here and the negative voltages
here which ways the current flow through
this resistor does it go from top to
bottom or bottom to top and the answer
is the positive current goes this way
goes down so that's I in this and the
current is going into the end with the
positive sign on the voltage now I'm
going to draw another one of these same
same sort of thing and we'll do it a
different way we'll do this one sideways
and I'll label the voltage here's R and
I'll put a voltage on it and the voltage
let's label it this way let's say this
we've labeled a plus in this way and
label the minus end this way
the question is which way is the current
go well the current goes in the positive
end so it goes in that way and that's
the sign convention for positive for
that that's per passive
components the current goes into the
current goes into the voltage on the
positive terminal of the voltage the
arrow over here like this that would
still mean the same thing it's still
going in the positive and coming out the
negative side so when we draw this for
capacitors and inductors let's draw a
capacitor over here and there's C and if
I label this with a voltage plus and
minus V then the passive sign convention
tells me that I label the positive
current going in I the same for an
inductor we'll draw our curly inductor
like that we'll put a voltage on this
time I'll put the voltage on this side
plus minus V plus minus V this is our
inductor like that and the current
the current goes in the top like that so
it goes in the same side as the plus and
the current comes out on the minus side
you can draw it either way you want
let's practice some more
this time we'll do it with a resistor
again here's another resistor and this
time I'm going to label the current
first I'm going to say I'm going to say
the current goes this way through the
resistor and now using the passive
component sign convention how do we
label the voltage I want to label the
voltage where's the plus sign plus sign
is on the side that the current goes in
the currents going in to this terminal
so that is the plus side of the resistor
and that's basically the idea of a sign
convention for passive components when
we're setting up a circuit if we have a
complicated circuit we're setting it up
we have to give names to all the
voltages and all the currents and this
is the way you do it to make sure that
Ohm's law comes out with the correct
sign that's what why we have this sign
convention